wenn du ein Entwicklungs Kampf fürs egal
ob du ihn gewinnst oder ob du verlierst
du wirst einfach traumatisiert ich habe
im Laufe der letzten Jahre so viele
Menschen kennenlernen die wirklich in
permanente Angst leben und dann finde
ich es geht so einfach nicht
[Musik]
Hallo und herzlich willkommen ich freue
mich sehr auf die Diskussion und starte
direkt mit der ersten Frage von dreizehn
Fragen mit unserer Konflikt Frage
musterstaat stärker in den Wohnungsmarkt
eingreifen wenn ihr seid ja er muss
stärker eingreifen um bezahlbares Wohnen
jetzt und auch in der Zukunft möglich zu
machen dann geht ihr aufs Grünefeld und
wenn ihr sagt nein er sollte echt nicht
stärker eingreifen dann geht er aufs
gelbe fällt dann könnt ihr euch jetzt
gerne positionieren
[Musik]
okay eure Position sind damit klar
kommen wir zum Thema
Immobilienspekulation Wohnungsmangel
immer weiter steigende Mieten der
Wohnraum in Deutschland Istra umkämpft
und für viele unbezahlbar wie also
schaffen wir in Zukunft bezahlbaren
Wohnraum für alle auf der einen Seite
werden Rufe nach starken Eingriffen des
Staates laut um Profit gear und
Verdrängung auf dem Wohnungsmarkt zu
beenden die andere Seite wiederum ist
sich sicher hier kann nur der freie
Markt Lösung finden
sich meine Gäste wie immer erstmal nicht
einig umso spannender also werden sie am
Ende der Folge dann doch ein Kompromiss
finden oder sich sogar auf eine Lösung
einigen können das werden wir am Ende
der Folge sehen was ist eure Meinung auf
welcher Seite würdet ihr stehen muss der
Staat stärker in den Wohnungsmarkt
eingreifen ja oder nein grün oder gelb
vielleicht ändert sich eure Meinung ja
sogar im Verlauf der Folge dann gilt ab
jetzt für euch liebe Gäste wenn der
anderen Seite zustimmt Volt in einem
Argument dann könnt ihr einen Schritt
auf die zugehen und wenn ihr vielleicht
auch während jemand anders noch redet
schon so sauer seid dass ihr das
irgendwie körperlich zum Ausdruck
bringen wollt dann könnt ihr einen
Schritt nach hinten gehen und für mich
ist natürlich das Ziel so viele wie
möglich von euch ja mannam Kompromiss
Fell zu sehen mal gucken ob das klappt
dann geht's los wenn mit dir du hast
sechs Jahre dafür gekämpft dass du in
mit deiner Familie in der Mietwohnung in
der du wohnst und gewohnt hast bleiben
kann jetzt mittlerweile ist klar du
darfst da bleiben warum solltet ihr da
überhaupt raus
Küchen Repressalien und Übergriffen
ausgesetzt ist und Wohnungsmarkt muss
ich definitiv ändern dass Menschen
wieder geschützt sind dass sie einfach
aus ihrem kunstmodus rauskommt ihre
Wohnung zu verlieren die Wohnung ist für
mich keine Ware sondern einfach wirklich
die die Grundbasis und drei sellschaft
wo die Menschen einfach Sicherheit haben
und leben müssen Immobilien finden immer
wieder Möglichkeiten die Wohnung zu
verbringen und das ist für mich ein
Problem und die Mieter sind in dem
Moment nicht Menschen sondern einfach
nur störende Objekte
ist der potenzielle Investoren dass man
immer wieder die Immobilie sanieren muss
sein auf ihren muss und alleine bei
solcher Investments, wirklich hohe
siebenstellige Beträge teilweise
zusammen und besser und sind die Miete
auch shop.at Investment irgendwann
natürlich auch zurückgeführt werden
müssen ich komme persönlich dass mein
mal die musste unterbrechen muss und
sagen muss bisschen mehr zum Eigentum
darüber hinaus dass die Regierung auch
die Chance im Möglichkeiten schaffen
müssen um einfach bezahlbare wohnen in
dem Bereich auch Eigentum um zu warten
dass die Leute die Möglichkeit haben
sich solche Wohnungen ganz einfach zu
leisten wenn das jetzt quasi schon fast
das hinterlassen
warum warum wolltest du so sehr an
der Zeit schon explodiert
ich jetzt fast verdoppelt und heißt die
wollen um wie ihre Wohnung sein für
10000 € in Quadratmeter kaufen das ist
einfach nicht leistbar und es ist auch
nicht mein Ziel für mich und meine
Familie bedeutet das einfach Freiheit zu
sagen ich habe hier eine Mietwohnung ich
möchte bezahlbare Miete zahlen gerne auf
an mein Eigentümer jeden aber ich möchte
wohl noch nicht kaufen. Du bist auch ein
Schritt aus wenn zu gegangen und ich
habe gerade wieder ein bisschen weil ich
denke also ich gebe Babs total recht und
wenn ich geb dir auch total rechne
entmietungs Praktiken Häuser auf zu
kaufen und sie bewusst auch viel zu
teuer natürlich zu sanieren um sie dann
bewusst auch an sehr wohlhabende
Menschen verkaufen zu wollen das ist was
wo ich mich absolut auch gegen
positionieren möchte der Kauf und die
Vermietung von Immobilien gerade aus
Sicht einer Privatperson aus Sicht einer
selbständigen wieder absolut die Chance
unabhängig im Alter zu sein finanzielle
Sicherheit zu erlangen die eigene Rente
zu erschaffen sich unabhängig zu machen
vom Start von staatlichen Systemen und
wirklich die volle Verantwortung zu
übernehmen aber ich finde es dir dieser
Haltung
jemand anderes soll das finanzielle
Risiko tragen jemand anderes soll im
Prinzip das instandhaltungs Risiko
tragen ich möchte ja nur
bezahlbar mieten also irgendwie müssen
sich ja also ich persönlich Vermieter 8
Wohnungen und irgendwie muss sich ja für
mich dieses Risiko auch ich muss es ja
händelbar haben sozusagen und dass du
dich da als Mitmieter klar ganz raus
ziehst
schwierig
regelmäßig jetzt gerade nicht weil ich
habe ja gerade gerade
in den letzten 15 Jahren ein kleines
Immobilien
Vermietung von Wohnungen
ich bin jetzt in Kassel Mannheim
Heidelberg Rhein-Neckar-Kreis TT gewesen
war teilweise auch in Osten wo die mit
derartig günstig waren also
Bautzen Zittau Nähe zur tschechischen
Grenze wieder rüber und da war das nicht
so brenzlig wird hier direkt in Berlin
das muss man auch dazu sagen Claudia
willst du sagen was ist Teil des
Problems
[Gelächter]
ich würde nicht sagen sie ist Teil des
Problems aber ich finde was wir
diskutieren verkennt ein bisschen was
eigentlich das Problem ist die
Wohnungsfrage ist vor allem dem Mieter
und MieterInnen Frage in Deutschland
also Vorkaufsrecht schön und gut Sven
hat er gesagt er will die Wohnung in er
kann auch weiß ich nicht die Wohnung gar
nicht kaufen für die meisten Menschen
ist das einfach ohne für sehr viele
Menschen gerade auf dem Berliner
Wohnungsmarkt und auf dem Wohnungsmarkt
in Großstädten ist das überhaupt keine
Option also wenn ich mit keinem oder
geringem Einkommen die haben ein riesen
Problem ihre miete zu zahlen eines der
größten Probleme für mich am deutschen
Wohnungsmarkt ist die Tatsache dass sehr
viele Menschen ihr Recht auf
angemessenen Wohnraum nicht wahrnehmen
kann das betrifft zB sehr sehr viele
Menschen die wohnungslos sind in
Deutschland reden wir da hier von 300
bis 500 000 Menschen die kein
mietvertraglich abgesicherten Wohnraum
haben in wen du bist gerade ein Schritt
zurück gegangen du bist selbst
Sozialarbeiterin und Aachen und täglich
in Kontakt mit Jugendlichen mit den
kontrolliert die in prekären
Lebenssituationen
kommst du da mit ihren Familien wohnen
müssen welche Bedeutung hat dein
Wohnraum eigentlich Wohnraum ist
Schutzraum vor allem für Menschen die
Raketen ratifiziert sind die eine
migrantische Biografie haben die Flucht
Erfahrung haben Traumata also all diese
Dinge die irgendwie ihren Alltag eben
auch
beeinflussen und ich denke dass wir vor
allem wenn wir über Wohnraum sprechen
auch die soziale Frage dahinter nicht
vergessen dürfen Diversität ist aktuell
nicht gewährleistet weil vor allem auch
marginalisierte Menschen Menschen mit
migrantischen Hintergrund beispielsweise
es sehr erschwert wird durch Rassismus
überhaupt Wohnungen zu finden viele an
den Rand der Städte ziehen müssen um
überhaupt bezahlbar wohnen zu können und
die Zugänge vor allem auch hinten in
Nastätten daneben privilegierten Gruppen
überlassen wird also ich finde die jetzt
die Frage nach Zugang zum Wohnraum ist
eine extrem wichtige und es gibt ja ganz
viele Gruppen in Deutschland die eben
kein Jungs freien Zugang zu Wohnraum
haben also du hast jetzt eine Gruppe
angesprochen wenn wir ich Forschung zu
wohnungslosen Menschen also versucht mal
mit letzter Meldeadresse Haftanstalt
oder letzter Meldeadresse städtische
Obdachlosenunterkunft was übrigens
extrem viele Menschen in Deutschland
betrifft irgendwie eine Wohnung zu
bekommen auf dem heiß umkämpften
Wohnungsmarkt aber selbst wenn es
Wohnung geben würde wären die Menschen
nicht diejenigen die die Wohnung
bekommen würden also denke gerade wenn
wir über diskriminierungsfreien Zugang
zum Wohnungsmarkt geben reden muss auf
jeden Fall was passieren
diskriminierungsfreier Zugang zum zu
Wohnraum in Deutschland würde dir da
einen Schritt auf Emilian und Claudia zu
gehen also das ist ein System gibt indem
Rassist Rassismus auch eine große Rolle
spielt da würdest du ja wenig erreicht
dass ich sie ihre wenige Vermieter
gehören die das so sehen ja Michael du
hast dich bewegt warum
ihnen aber im System ist sehr das auch
so
dominiert
Wettbewerbe und ja Profitinteressen und
von daher ja eben Diskriminierung die
lösen und die wir brauchen die haben
gleichseitigen Sozialamt sowie und
ökologischen Aspekten zu tun was heißt
du musst und günstig bauen wir müssen
auf Mac verhüten Wohnungen auskommen und
das geht nur wenn Leute es verstehen und
ja unterstützen wollen deswegen mussten
die Lösungen eben aus der Befruchtung
kommen wenn wir jetzt den Wohnungsmarkt
hauptsächlich dem freien Markt
überlassen würden würde dann diese
soziale Durchmischung überhaupt noch
stattfinden die du angesprochen hast ich
glaube das nicht weil es eben halt um
diese soziale Frage auch geht und in die
kann nur tatsächlichen Unterstützung mit
dem Staat auch umgesetzt werden und das
eben auch strukturell und wenn der Staat
sich da völlig
ostseethermen wir einfach auch gar keine
richtige Basis um zu entscheiden und um
strukturelle Änderungen eben auch
einsetzen zu können sagst wird der Start
ist da deine sehr groß ist eine wichtige
Rolle und auch eine große Verantwortung
Michael wie siehst du das ja das denke
ich auch also ich denke sowas wie
Aufladen wie viel soziale Wohnungen in
Neubauprojekten mit entstehen müssen die
Auflagen die es ja auch heute schon gibt
die sind absolut berechtigt und auch
total angebracht habt sind denn dann die
Investoren das Problem also ich glaube
nicht dass nur die Investoren Problem
darstellen muss die Investoren auch
unterscheiden ich gehöre ihr zu den
Bayern holt Königinnen Queen wo ich sag
ok ich kaufe ich werde bis auf ich
renoviere und behalte das im Bestand mit
meinem Mieter und wenn wir erhöhen dann
erhöhen wir erklaere 50 € vielleicht
einmal in drei Jahre und ja natürlich
habe ich schon gesagt bekommen ja eure
mit Potenzial ist ja riesig aber ich
kann ja ich habe Leute drin wohnen
kinderwohnung ich glaube nicht dass eine
meine älteste MieterInnen sich dagegen
nur 12 € 13:15 Uhr leisten können und
deshalb mache ich es nicht weil weil es
geht mir auch so gut das muss ich dazu
sagen dass er tatsächlich
Wohnraum spekulieren möchte der darf
eigentlich aus meiner Sicht am Markt
nicht agieren weil Wohnraum ist kein
spekulations gut ist auch für mich kein
spekulations gut ich kaufe die Wohnungen
um sie lange zu behalten für mich ist
das meine Altersvorsorge wir haben auch
ein marodes Rentensystem und das geht
also aus meiner Perspektive mit
langfristigen und guten Verhältnissen zu
mieten und MieterInnen und Spekulationen
auf auf Preissteigerungen Leerstand
herbeizuführen auf unbebaute Objekte zu
spekulieren das ist eine Geschichte wo
ich finde da kann ein Staat auch
eingreifen auf Wohnraum darf nicht
spekuliert werden da sind ja alle ein
Schritt nach vorne gegangen Claudia
Warum bist du ein Schritt nach vorn
gegangen ich bin ein Schritt nach vorne
gegangen weil ich Michael nicht zustimme
aus ist einfach eine Frage von Recht und
Pflicht also Deutschland ist zur
Umsetzung von internationalen
Menschenrechtsverträge verpflichtet weil
es die ratifiziert hat und dazu gehört
auch das Recht auf wohnen das heißt der
Staat muss das Recht auf bezahlbares und
angemessenes wohnen für alle
gewährleisten und ein Baustein ist eben
sowas zu unterbinden ich glaube dass die
Politik andere Lösungsansätze schaffe
muss verdient ganz normale Leute für die
ganz normale Mieter Wohnraum zu
erreichen aber und andere Bedingungen ja
Steuerbegünstigungen einfach billigere
Kredite geben und dass sie dann
zukünftig auf unsere Kinder gerade die
migrationskinder sind doch die Kinder
die dann Deutschland zukünftig aufbauen
werden oder nach wie vor Wirtschaft ich
dafür sorgen dass wir wenn es überhaupt
noch Rente geben würde in Rente haben
inzwischen
privat
Profi Profit interessierten Investoren
und Bau und Wohngenossenschaft in die
tendenziell in der
Gemeinwohlorientierung cercle sich
befinden das macht ein riesen
Unterschied der Staat hat eben
Spielregeln festgehalten und da da bin
ich also nicht zunächst verstaatlichen
Losungen aber der Staat sollte doch
sagen können eine Mehrheit von der
Nationen sollten bitteschön eine Wohnung
finden auch bezahlbar auch in einer
Nachbarschaft würde gerne wohnen und das
sind die gemeinwohlorientierten aussieht
wie wohnen Baugenossenschaft ab die sind
nicht mit privat
profitorientierten zu vergleichen
sehr großen Sinn für geweint wohl hat
und aussieht wie wichtig das ist eben
halt auch Orte zu schaffen in den
Menschen sich begegnen kann und zusammen
kommen können
und das funktioniert auch sehr gut und
ich weiß aber eben auch dass das jetzt
nicht unbedingt
Paradebeispiel für überall in
Deutschland ist ich denke aber wenn
solche Prozesse oder Strukturen eben
auch staatlich gefördert werden würden
dass das auch einfach löschen deckender
wirken könnte Michael du besitzt einige
Immobilien bist also Vermieterin und du
Coach sogar auch Frauen zum Thema
Altersvorsorge durch Immobilien kaufen
welche Gefahr siehst du denn jetzt wenn
sie wenn der Staat in den Wohnungsmarkt
eingreifen würde
aber kommt ja an auf die Frage wie der
Staat eingreifen würde was dafür für
mich natürlich
schwierig oder problematisch ist es wenn
wir über die die Einnahmenseite sprechen
also über die Mieteinnahmen Seite weil
ich denke langfristig ich finanziere
über 30 Jahre das soll am Ende wenn ich
in in Rente gehe soll es im Prinzip
meinen meinen Lebensunterhalt bezahlen
und wenn ich dann auf der auf der
Einnahmenseite im Prinzip nicht
kalkulieren kann weil das ein ein
riesen? Ist dann ist das für mich für
mich schwierig also eine staatliche
Regulierungen kann ich mir eher
vorstellen wie und wo wollen wir
Wohnraum schaffen welche Wohnkonzepte
wollen wir fördern aber diese Garten
mieten Deckel mieten Begrenzung
mietenstopp Diskussionen
deutschlandweit das ist für mich was was
ich ja was mir einfach die Planungen
erschwert Herr Sven kannst du das
verstehen dass dass Michael die Planung
erschwert und dass sie das stört ja kann
ich absolut verstehen ich werde ich
Unternehmer sind wir erstmal damit
Einnahmen Ausgaben keine Frage aber
irgendwo glaube ich muss man trotzdem
einfach mal sagen warte mal hier es muss
was passiert also wir müssen Bild nach
außen erzeugen das einfach wirklich
diese ganzen Spekulanten die wir jetzt
gemeinsam mit übel und Problem
festgestellt haben dass sie einfach
abgeschreckt werden und da sind eben
natürlich so eine Diskussion
geführt wurde und der mieten Deckel und
diese Demos und alles was jeder
irgendwie jeder Widerstand in dieser
Stadt
zur Verfügung
steht für Menschenrechte und
wohnungslose Menschen
mit denen dieses Wohnungsmarkt warum
verlieren die ihre Wohnungen ganz viele
Menschen leben auf der Straße
sehe
auf dem Sofa bei Bekannten oder Freunden
das betrifft vor allem wohnungslos
Frauen und vor allem ganz viele wohnen
in den kommunalen Wohnungslosen
Unterkünften und wir reden hier wirklich
von großen Zahlen also in Berlin sind
das 35000 Leute in Nordrhein-Westfalen
sind das ungefähr 30000 Menschen den
kommunalen Wohnungslosen Unterkünften
wohnen und davon ein Viertel Kinder und
diese Menschen wurden dort auf engsten
Raum teilweise nicht immer aber unter
absolut menschenunwürdigen Bedingungen
und haben auch keine Chance wieder eine
Wohnung auf dem normalen Wohnungsmarkt
zu bekommen im weil sie die aller selbst
wenn es Wohnung gibt sind sie die
allerletzten die dafür in Frage kommen
das heißt sie bleiben teilweise auf
Monate und Jahre in diesem kommunalen
Unterkünften
Leben weg weil das was wir legt sich
schlafen mit dem Grundgesetz unterm
Kopfkissen saß einfach die Wohnung ist
unverletzlich und was ist einfach aus
dem Dornröschenschlaf auf und nachts
einfach aber das ist die Realität die
Wohnung ist schon lange nicht mehr und
verletzlich und heißt ich kann mir nicht
sicher sein dass ich morgen heute meine
Wohnung nach habe ich habe im Laufe der
letzten Jahre so viele Menschen
kennenlernen die wirklich in permanente
Angst leben und dann finde ich es geht
so einfach nicht Herr der Stichwort
Stichwort permanente Angst wie ist denn
die Perspektive werden noch mehr
Menschen ihre Wohnungen verlieren mit
was kann man denn da rechnen finde
Entwicklung ich habe natürlich keine
Glaskugel wo ich in die Zukunft schauen
können aber also ich sehe schon schwarz
wenn nicht der Staat Stärke eingreift
und die Rahmenbedingungen dafür setzt
das eben wohnen bezahlbar bleibt für
alle Menschen und dass die Menschen auch
unter menschenwürdigen Bedingungen
wohnen können also ich möchte gerne auf
einen Punkt eingehen in Sven gesagt hat
sie wachen früh mit der Angst auf ja und
vielleicht bleiben sie dann auch in der
Wohnung obwohl sie eigentlich schon die
miete gar nicht mehr stemmen können also
die mietbelastungsquote die Frage wie
viel ich von meinem Einkommen ausgebe
für die Miete die ist gerade bei bei
Haushalten mit wenig Einkommen extrem
hoch die geben teilweise 30 40 % des
Einkommens für die Miete aus der bleibt
nicht mehr viel übrig am Ende des Monats
also das ist wirklich auch eine Frage
von der von Existenzangst so wie du das
geschildert hast Michael du bist der
erste der im Kompromiss Feld mit einem
halben Fuß gelandet ist
10 Einheiten oder 100 oder Saft 1000
Einheiten ist fängt mit den Zähnen 15 in
Berlin an die mehr als 3000 deswegen
kann ich damit gut leben und sagen ja
ist eine Krise da mussten eigentlich den
Menschen entgegen kommen die gestresst
sind oder die sind schon obdachlos oder
damals bedroht da das finde ich ja
korrekt
sowieso in einem Kies und einem Viertel
Leben sich zusammentun und diese
Konzepte arbeiten sondern eben auch mit
anderen Menschen aus anderen
Stadtgebieten vielleicht auch erst im
Ausseer aus der Grenze oder außerhalb
der Innenstadt zusammenkommen und daran
arbeiten und alle eben aber auch gleich
berechtigt sind darin um wirklich auch
neue Ideen erschaffen zu können wir
glaube darum geht dass wir verstehen wir
sind die Leute die die Zukunft und die
Gesellschaft gestalten nicht
irgendjemand aus dieser Verantwortung
kann sich niemand raus ziehen und wenn
es wirklich wichtig dass wir auch nicht
mit der Forderung zu sagen die Politik
muss etwas regulieren ich ziemlich dann
nicht aus der Verantwortung ich bin
mittendrin und du musst nur glücklich
jeder verstehen dass er an der Stelle
mit den Ressourcen die er hat irgendwie
die Welt vielleicht an dem Tag ein
bisschen besser macht so und dann finde
ich es sind schon in Ordnung
ich einen Kompromissvorschlag an euch
und mal sehen ob er einen Schritt auf
mich zu geht ihr seid ja alle schon sehr
nah dran am Kompromiss Feld oder fast
drin also kann uns alle darauf einigen
dass Wohnraum kein Spekula Jungs gut
essen
gehen einen Schritt auf mich zu
babson bisschen zögerlich warum so ein
kleinen zögerlichen Schritt nur also ich
bin definitiv nicht gegen den
Spekulanten was man übersehen muss das
tatsächlich die Investoren die sind die
auf die Innenstadt das schöner gemacht
haben hat sich damit spekuliert wird in
dem Forum was Dir widerfahren ist ist
absolut nicht akzeptabel dann lass uns
gern zu den Lösungen kommen ihr könnt
jetzt nämlich jeweils auf jeder Seite
des Feldes einmal die grüne Seite aber
die gelbe Seite die Köpfe
zusammenstecken wie in der Schule
Gruppenarbeit habt ihr jetzt ein paar
Minuten Zeit und könnt euch einen
konkreten Vorschlag überlegen den ihr
der anderen Seite dann gleich
präsentiert und ihr könnt ruhig
überlegen es kann natürlich eine
politische Forderung sein es kann auch
wirklich eine konkrete Maßnahme sein
also seid ihr gerne kreativ und dann
geht's los will ich sagen
[Musik]
was für Erfahrung habt ihr denn mit
staatlichen Maßnahmen gemacht welche
funktionieren welche funktionieren gar
nicht schreibt gerne mal in die
Kommentare
[Musik]
dann will ich jetzt mit euch der grünen
Seite anfangen was habt ihr euch
überlegt
[Musik]
Land die soziale Situation immer Brenner
ja wird das so einfach wirklich extreme
Anspannung gibt und dass am Ende wendet
ihr wirklich richtig knallt weil die
Menschen nichts mehr zu verlieren haben
das dann keinen von uns geholfen ist am
Ende wollen wir doch alle die gleiche
wir wollen Frieden leben wir wollen dass
unsere Kinder gesund sind dass sie
einfach mal um die dass die Welt weiter
besteht und dass wir irgendwie
miteinander klarkommen Meike was hat
mich gerade daran überzeugt
irgendwie
[Musik]
ihr seid ihr jetzt gerne fragen was für
ein Kompromissvorschlag habt ihr euch
überlegt außer der Punkt ist ich hoffe
ich kann das sagen von uns aus gesehen
quasi vom Staat aus vom Folk über die
Wartung und Politik
bezahlbare Wohnungen
zu fördern bzw bauen zu lassen das heißt
weniger zu bestrafen und mehr zu fördern
wenn wir Bauherren
Investoren auch Genossenschaften kennen
finden in Wirkung lassen dann suchen wir
dich fördern wenn die
uns damit helfen aus Wohnung Wohnungen
bezahlbar
herzustellen und auch noch lang
Frühstück zu verwalten reicht dieser
Kompromissvorschlag
[Musik]
also in der Richtung in die er geht ja
aber einfach mal in der aktuellen
Situation in der wir uns gerade befinden
schon ganz viele schritte nein nein wir
haben hier eine Situation die lässt sich
mit wir bauen und wir machen alle
irgendwie schön und mit grünen Wiesen
dann lässt sich nicht mehr lösen wir sie
brennt hier schon einfach mal die Leute
sie verlassen reihenweise die Stadt
Janse in den letzten 10 Jahren also das
heißt wir sind mittendrin und da ist das
einfach ein bisschen zu zu netto
perspektivisch und zu eiapopeia gedacht
hier ist wirklich hier ist Kampf
Brutalität und wirklich Gewalt an der
Tagesordnung bei der Verdrängung von
Mietern und da ist es aus meiner Sicht
nicht ausreichend nicht zufrieden Freude
Eierkuchen denn du bist ein Schritt auf
der anderen Seite ich find den
Kompromissvorschlag gut also letztlich
geht's ja doch darum dass der Staat
Rahmenbedingungen schafft und euer
Vorstand ist ja dass er nicht straff
sondern dass er das positiv Anreize
geschafft werden und da kann man ja über
viele Sachen nachdenken Belegungsbindung
und was weiß ich was
Investitionsförderung deshalb finde ich
den Vorschlag gut also steht das das
eine von dem möglichen Lösung erste Mal
seit acht Jahren wieder ruhig schlafen
weil ich weiß es gibt so eine Vermieter
und wenn ich irgendwann für den Berliner
Wohnungsmarkt bin ich verbrannt wenn ich
mit der Wohnung verliere bin ich nicht
obdachlos und dann kann einfach zu Dir
gehen also das ist einfach diesen
klassischen Vermieter noch gibt darüber
freue ich mich sehr ich habe das dessen
dass der
Mieter hier gerade in Berlin dass der
Markt so angespannt ist was wir
vielleicht überhaupt nicht bewusst war
ist er schon Brutalität die Vermieter
ihre Mieter letztendlich entgegentreten
und das war für mich teilweise
schockierend niemand soll sich denn
gegenüber am einfach so verhalten und
eins ist klar da sollte tatsächlich der
Staat für leichten Forderungen
erschaffen für uns Investoren die dann
bezahlbare Wohnraum kaufen renovieren
sanieren und den Mietern zur Verfügung
stellen gerade aktuell war ja würde ich
mir wünschen dass das Grundrecht auf
wohnen vielmehr verankert wird in
innenpolitischen ja Agenda dass vielmehr
Parteien auch das wirklich auch als eine
ihrer Grundprinzipien aufnehmen und
dabei eben auch die Menschen die vor
allem davon betroffen sind und zwar die
Mieter innen mit einbezogen werden in
den Prozess dann danke ich vielmals für
diese Diskussion
natürlich nicht
[Musik]